was there a point where the Black Keys
got kind of too big it didn't get too
big it's just we toured too much and
just weren't too hard and and the reason
that we did that was because we spent so
long making absolutely no money that
when all of a sudden were making we go
spend like them playing shows for nobody
and it never it never really got old but
you know but when the people started
showing up and all these things all
these opportunities started presenting
themselves that we never had like we
played Lollapalooza we played Coachella
we played reading the leads but like in
the small tents or you know not on the
main stage or whatever it is and before
you know it it's like you're gonna
headline this you're gonna have - all
these people want to see you it you
can't say no to the work and it the
shows are a lot of fun it's addictive
the problem is is you start you
gradually this whaling down like your
psyche and what you're able to process
and part of the thing with touring is
it's not just the time on the road and
you know that's good you travel a time
it's anticipating the travel that's
about to come and adjust into coming
back off the travel that you can maybe
do six months of traveling on a record
button and coming and going it makes you
feel like you were gone all year that's
how we felt for 2010 through 2015 right
but on top of that when you're on the
road you don't you don't get to create
music they're just performing yeah so it
can get it can become Groundhog Day
really quickly and yeah I mean we
started as a recording project yeah you
know neither of us have like have this
crazy desire to be in front of people
all the time you know what I mean it's
just happened to turn out that way but
we need to make music it's something we
have to do we haven't got to be able to
do it so moving forward I think the idea
is that were just we've got to be better
balanced mm-hmm you know got to be
proactive about it you you've just you
described in one interview I read you
described being on stage playing music
and thinking about something else
entirely oh yeah I could like I could be
constructing things in my head and then
play the songs they were I had him I had
the song so down yeah that must have
felt I mean we wouldn't even soundcheck
we'd go play in front of 20,000 people
and I wouldn't even soundcheck it was
just like I know what it's gonna sound
like
I know you know what I mean I was just
like yeah must've felt kind of weird
though
very weird yeah yeah it's really weird
were you always figuring you'd come back
to this did you have any doubts at any
point I didn't have any doubts mm-hmm
I figured we'd get back together when
the time was right mm-hmm yeah yeah I I
knew it would come around at some point
and I was I honestly really enjoyed the
time not being on the road and I also
really enjoyed coming back into the full
of the band with the appreciation of
what we've accomplished and also
understanding really what being cautious
about what we bite off yeah what we
agreed to do this what we've agreed to
do so far we've announced 32 or 33 shows
so far there's gonna be some more shows
but you know it's not gonna be the
hundred and twenty and eight welcome you
know to her you know yeah we won't do
that again
they won't well we might depends if if
it's like everything's up for
negotiation